[Music]
this amoeba is making its home out of a
drop of water taken from a larger sample
and then sandwiched between a glass
slide and the coverslip before being
placed onto a microscope oh so carefully
and perched above is us peering down
through the lens to see a magnified
version of its daily life and coming
from underneath that slide is white
light often passing through microbial
bodies so that they appear transparent
like moving outlines but white light is
a fracture able thing made up of
different wavelengths that can interact
in their own particular ways with the
world they encounter absorbed by some
materials and reflected by others for
wavelengths that lie in the visible
spectrum that reflected light gives us
color at the inside of this ciliate it's
clear body rendered kaleidoscopic
following a colorful meal
[Music]
we often link color to perception how we
see it how it makes us feel how we pick
and choose our favorites colors signal
not just like traffic lights but in
nature feathers that attract bright
markings that warn and patterns that
camouflage but setting aside our own
voyeurism there are no complex eyes on
you when you're microscopic the colors
that emerge are entirely incidental in a
sense stripped down to their fundamental
natures the product of light absorbing
and reflecting at different wavelengths
these colors do not exist to communicate
or signal they're just the color they
are and when we find beauty here it's
not because there's any advantage to
that beauty it's just luck maybe the
easiest color to translate from what we
see on a daily basis to what we observe
under the microscope is green the color
of photosynthesis and thus of many
plants and photosynthetic microbes this
is of course not a coincidence but a
monochromatic pattern of evolution and
endosymbiosis the product of an ancient
cyanobacterium that made its home in a
plant and brought the green pigment
chlorophyll along for the ride when
light hits chlorophyll the molecule
absorbs energy from the red and blue
wavelengths exciting electrons and
powering the reactions that produce
storages of chemical energy what remains
to the observer to us are the green
wavelengths that reflect other
photosynthetic microbes rely on
chlorophyll as well sometimes containing
different forms of the pigment that
allow them to access other wavelengths
of light while chlorophyll is essential
to cyanobacteria the cyano in their name
implies another important color blue
this is the product of phycocyanin which
combined with chlorophyll gives the
organisms that color that makes them
often known as blue green algae
phycocyanin is an accessory pigment it's
nature's way of hedging it's
photosynthetic bets relying strictly on
chlorophyll after all would restrict
what kind of light an organism can take
advantage of for cyanobacteria this can
be particularly problematic if that
light gets absorbed by water or by other
organisms above them so it relies on
Assemblies of phycocyanin to absorb
additional wavelengths creating
alternate sources of excitation energy
for photosynthesis but there are as
always exceptions other microbes use a
class of molecules called carotenoids as
accessory pigments which bring pops of
yellow orange and red
like chlorophylls these are a type of
chemistry that we're familiar with from
plants and vegetables we see every day
like the orange carotene of carrots
translate them into the microbial world
and you get diatoms like this one
it's a beautiful golden brown color
derived from the carotenoid of Fuko
xanthine but carotenoids can serve other
purposes like the red pigment
astaxanthin which we see on a more
regular basis in the pinkish color of
shrimp the most plentiful source of
astaxanthin is this microscopic Hamada
caucus which we found in a cemetery
birdbath when conditions are good the
Hamada caucus is green but if the Sun
becomes too intense or nutrients becomes
scarce they form protective cysts and
produce large amounts of astaxanthin
which shields the cells from harmful
ultraviolet light
these cysts are almost indestructible
valiant against chemical and mechanical
attempts to break into them until
conditions return to normal allowing the
Hamada Cass
to do the same you Galina sang when I
use astaxanthin to protect themselves as
well
rapidly reddening in response to large
amounts of light to protect themselves
from the dangerous rays of the Sun these
pigments have implications beyond their
microbial uses or even their visceral
beauty scientists have converted
pigments like phycocyanin into a
fluorescent tool that allows us to map
out the interiors of other cells and
Hamada caucus and diatoms are objects of
study for the potential health benefits
their carotenoids may confirm their
colors are observed and utilitarian in
our hands guiding and identifying and
indicating earlier we stated a simple
premise of the micro cosmos that its
inhabitants live in a world largely
unobserved we made that statement while
casually setting aside the obvious that
you and I we are here watching these
microbes both colorful and not they did
not evolve to be seen in fact we went
almost our entire history without ever
seeing one but now they have certainly
captured our attention these colors
developed long before we were around to
notice them independent of our
preferences and our needs but we have
bodies and minds that evolved to take
note even the examples we've highlighted
today emphasize our own observational
bias focusing on wavelengths that are
visible to us as a species even while
light extends far beyond that spectrum
color is to us often subjective
but it's a product of light of physics
and of chemistry that has impacts at all
scales even if the way we process it
varies the underlying physics does not
what the micro cosmos helps us
understand is that there is more to
color than what we see that our
perception of it is only one facet of
what it means to live in an illuminated
world thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us journey to the
micro cosmos is a production of
complexly which is a company that makes
stuff for YouTube and right now at
complexly we're trying something really
new which I earn three new things it's a
pilot season we're launching three
brand-new shows each on their own
channel and each will run for three
episodes and then we'll decide if any of
those will continue on now we love all
of these ideas but we can't make all of
them happen so we'd love your feedback
and what you think should continue
please check them out and share your
thoughts and thank you to all of these
people who support this channel on
patreon so that we can continue making
these very cool videos if you would like
to join them and we would love it if you
did you can check us out at patreon.com
slash journey to micro and if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram
you
[Music]